hi you must be Liam hey buddy how are
you feeling today I'm feeling fine dr.
Gupta July this is Lillian glass she's
from the Make A Wish Foundation Marion
how are you feeling today Liam I'm fine
Marion glass okay well I have some news
that might make you feel a little better
huh we even Make A Wish Foundation make
dreams come true for little boys and
little girls who are very sick
just like you there are no children like
me Marion it's not you're one of a kind
but we're gonna make any dream come true
that you could ever have okay anything
that's right buddy
that's right would would you like to
play with your favorite basketball team
Oh what about being Superman for a day I
wish to drown me
what to drowning me in the bathtub no
holding our last breath escapes his body
even water
all the while singing
[Music]
Liam should surely we don't want to hurt
other people now do we kiddo any
anything else flying or hot-air balloon
or meet a celebrity my new wish is to
lean over the body of a dying man and
put my lips on his stealing his last
breath no absolutely not
I don't even know where you're I wish to
take all the prosthetic legs in the
hospital and drove when massive creature
hey Liam I am so sorry miss gloss it's
all right he he doesn't know what he's
saying I wish to pee in your mouth what
both of you mine especially you oh I
wish to pee in both of your mouths as I
stand over you I'll need a glass of
water and nothing dr. Gupta no you are
reprehensible you are evil you are a
different silent dr. Gupta he's not a
devil child he's just a child
you have no business working in a
pediatric ward what I'm gonna report you
[Music]
you really have said marry my thing
you've made me question everything that
I've ever believed about the essential
goodness it
[Music]
[Applause]
brothers and sister tonight the newest
member of our family will feast for the
first time
bring the new blood
[Applause]
brother Tyrell welcome to the first
night of your new and what are we
wearing here I'm just wearing what I got
bit in mm-hmm okay
do you have anything black or like pants
with laces up the side of the leg to be
quick just so you can still see the skin
oh no that's not my style so I got
nothing in my closet or nothing like
that
okay anyway we will tonight Oh see
[Music]
[Applause]
come on man excuse me I'm just saying
y'all over here licking and and hissing
and whatnot if we don't eat then let's
eat
damn yes of course we will all feed
[Music]
spread the meat
[Applause]
[Music]
the enemy of that actually get in your
mouth because I mean now soon the one
y'all is hungry out of time oh no no no
no see
look why y'all gotta hiss when you
flashin your fangs you know you can make
your teeth come out with y'all doing all
that nonsense see and can you two get a
room seriously y'all live in a damn
mention they got to be some other place
you can do that I mean are you two even
lesbians I just don't understand why
everything gotta be all sexual and licky
girls seriously man you got to get your
hands that bought me you up nasty
creepy is touching my nipple for 15
minutes the audit Charlie's doing up in
here this is just like straight-up
gratuitous I got bit on purpose so I
could live forever see future cars yes
Cyrus these pants are uncomfortable and
I actually have a boyfriend and this
song has been playing for like two years
and it sucks this just seems desperate
okay desperate really Tristan it's
Christian really his name ain't even
Tristan so do you all feel this way yeah
yeah kinda yeah wow it's like you can't
even get good friends no you're not even
okay and you're leaving now that's me
you know what no seriously like you
could fix this place up it'd be dope
though for real our cars gonna be able
to fly or is everything going to be on a
magnetic track that's no big deal
this old negative tastes like pennies oh
hey come on nipple play is for private
family or just like 2011 it's just a
drink both you guys
[Music]
roommate meeting don't go what the hell
it's got a hangover
I don't give up about your hangover okay
Brendan I want a roommate meeting I want
it now okay somebody's been taking out
of the fridge Raider and throwing it on
the ground and it's pissing me off
is this another one of your stupid
pranks jonald no and your pranks are
stupid is that you Monday
what I said somebody's been taking out
of the fridge and throw it on the ground
and I want to know who it is because
it's not funny but what I want to know
is who keeps pulling the sheets off my
bed and hanging them from the ceiling
fan at night was that you Monday have
you been taking everybody's sheets off
them in the night and hanging them from
the ceiling fans what no well clearly
someone's been doing that whoa who did
that yeah we even talking about right
now did you throw that bottle jonald no
go go I totally think you can throw that
bottle Brendon yeah you would do that
Freddie no well somebody threw that in
bottle and you're the one who drew dicks
on everyone's floor area so this is just
destructive what about you Monday did
you throw that bottle
what bottle bottle dude it's a smash
against the wall got it
why didn't throw the bottle obviously it
wasn't ping he's got the best grades in
the house
good pointing come on guys let's cool it
with the profanity Ino pings very
religious
[Music]
hi listen up
Sheriff's Department close by we'll be
safe there okay stay close I'll get you
out of here
okay we're still keep it together yeah
we gotta make sure that sheriff's
station
[Music]
we gotta go through them stay together
keep moving and don't get bitch
[Music]
are you gonna mess up what is up high
schoo
[Music]
that's these are some racist mother and
zombies why would you even lock the door
I mean the windows broken oh hell no no
no no
Oh what is that they seriously wouldn't
let her eat us hey guys isn't this great
these racist zombies leaving us alone
come on we having a party
[Music]
[Applause]
you